Como humanos, está en nuestra naturaleza
querer mejorar nuestra salud y minimizar el sufrimiento.
Sin importar lo que la vida tenga para darnos,
ya sea cáncer, diabetes, enfermedades cardíacas,
o incluso fracturas de huesos, buscamos recuperarnos.
Soy jefa de un laboratorio de biomateriales
y realmente estoy fascinada de la forma en que los humanos
han usado materiales de la manera más creativa
en su cuerpo a lo largo del tiempo.
Tomemos como ejemplo este bello caparazón de nácar azul.
De hecho, lo usaban los mayas
como diente artificial.
No estamos seguros del porqué lo hacían.
Es duro. Es duradero.
Pero también tenía otras propiedades muy buenas.
De hecho, cuando lo colocaban en la mandíbula,
podía integrarse a ella.
Y actualmente sabemos, gracias a tecnologías
de imágenes muy sofisticadas,
que parte de esa integración se debe al hecho
de que este material está diseñado
de una manera muy específica: tiene una hermosa química,
una hermosa arquitectura.
Y creo que, de algún modo, podríamos pensar
en el uso del caparazón azul de nácar y los mayas
como la primera aplicación real
de la tecnología Bluetooth.
(Risas)
Pero si avanzamos y pensamos a lo largo de la historia
cómo los humanos han usado diferentes materiales en el cuerpo,
a menudo encontraremos que los médicos
han sido bastante creativos.
Han usando cosas comunes y corrientes.
Uno de mis ejemplos favoritos
es el de Sir Harold Ridley,
que fue un oftalmólogo famoso,
o que se convirtió en un oftalmólogo famoso.
Y durante la 2ª Guerra Mundial, vio
a pilotos que volvían de sus misiones
y notó que dentro de sus ojos
tenían fragmentos pequeños de material
alojados dentro del ojo.
Pero lo más interesante
era que el material no estaba causando
ninguna reacción inflamatoria.
Al investigar el caso, descubrió
que, en realidad, se trataba de pequeños fragmentos de plástico
que provenían de la cubierta exterior de los aviones Spitfires.
Y esto lo llevó a proponer aquel material
como nuevo material para lentes intraoculares.
Se llama PMMA y actualmente se usa
en millones de personas por año,
y ayuda a prevenir cataratas.
Creo que ese ejemplo es espléndido
porque nos recuerda que en aquellos días
los materiales se elegían con frecuencia
porque eran bioinertes.
Su propósito era cumplir una función mecánica.
Se los podría poner en el cuerpo
sin que causaran una reacción adversa.
Y lo que quiero mostrarles es
que, en medicina regenerativa,
ya nos alejamos de esa idea
de tomar un material bioinerte.
En cambio, buscamos materiales
que sean bioactivos, que interactúen con el cuerpo,
y que además podamos ponerlos en el cuerpo,
que cumplan su función,
y que luego se disuelvan con el tiempo.
Si miramos este esquema,
se ve lo que consideramos
el procedimiento típico en la ingeniería de tejidos.
Tenemos células allí, normalmente del paciente.
Podemos ponerlas sobre un material
y podemos hacer que ese material sea muy complejo si queremos.
Luego, podemos hacerlo crecer en el laboratorio
o podemos colocárselo directamente al paciente.
Y este es un procedimiento que se usa en todo el mundo,
incluyendo nuestro laboratorio.
Pero una de las cosas que es de gran importancia
cuando pensamos en células madre
es que obviamente las células madre pueden ser muchas cosas diferentes,
y quieren ser muchas cosas diferentes,
por lo que queremos estar seguros de que el ambiente
en que las colocamos tenga la información suficiente
para que devengan el tipo correcto
de tejido especializado.
Y si pensamos en los diferentes tipos de tejidos
que se buscan regenerar
en todo el mundo, en los diferentes laboratorios del mundo,
son casi todos los tejidos que podemos imaginar.
Y de hecho, la estructura de esos tejidos
es bien diferente y dependerá realmente
de si el paciente tiene alguna enfermedad subyacente,
u otros problemas, para saber cómo
regenerarán ese tejido.
Y deberán pensar en los materiales
que usarán con mucho cuidado,
en su bioquímica, su mecánica,
y muchas otras propiedades también.
Todos nuestros tejidos tienen capacidades muy diferentes para regenerarse.
Y aquí vemos al pobre Prometeo,
que eligió un camino algo complicado
y fue castigado por los dioses griegos.
Lo ataron a una roca y un águila lo visitaba
a diario para comerle su hígado.
Pero obviamente su hígado se regeneraba cada día.
Y así, día tras día, fue castigado
eternamente por los dioses.
El hígado se regenerará de esta maravillosa manera.
Pero si pensamos en otros tejidos,
como el cartílago, por ejemplo,
ante el menor corte, les resultará
muy difícil regenerar ese cartílago.
Por lo que varía mucho de tejido a tejido.
El hueso es algo intermedio
y es uno de los tejidos en el que trabajamos en nuestro laboratorio.
El hueso es bastante bueno para regenerarse.
Debe serlo. Probablemente todos hemos tenido fracturas
en algún momento.
Y una de las maneras en las que pueden pensar
en reparar la fractura
es este procedimiento, llamado extracción de hueso de la cresta ilíaca.
Lo que el cirujano podría hacer
es tomar algo de hueso de la cresta ilíaca,
que está justo aquí,
y luego trasplantarlo en algún otro lugar del cuerpo.
Y funciona realmente bien
porque es hueso propio
y está bien vascularizado,
lo que significa que tiene una muy buena provisión de sangre.
Pero el problema es que hay un límite
y además, cuando se hace esa operación,
los pacientes podrían sufrir dolor significativo
en la zona afectada incluso dos años después de la operación.
Por eso, lo que pensamos es
que ciertamente hay una gran necesidad de reparar el hueso,
pero este tipo de técnica de la cresta ilíaca
realmente tiene muchas limitaciones.
¿Acaso no podríamos recrear
la generación de hueso dentro del cuerpo
a pedido, para luego poder transplantarlo
evitando estos efectos posteriores tan dolorosos
que se tendrían con la extracción de hueso de la cresta ilíaca?
Y eso es lo que hicimos y la forma en que lo hicimos
fue volviendo a este típico método de ingeniería de tejido
pero pensándolo de un modo diferente.
Y lo simplificamos mucho,
por lo que nos deshicimos de muchos de estos pasos.
Nos deshicimos de la necesidad de extraer células del paciente,
de la necesidad de introducir químicos muy sofisticados
y nos deshicimos de la necesidad
de cultivar estas estructuras en el laboratorio.
Y en lo que nos enfocamos realmente
fue en nuestro sistema material y en hacerlo más simple.
Pero como lo usamos de forma muy ingeniosa,
pudimos generar cantidades enormes de hueso
usando este método.
Es decir, estábamos usando el cuerpo
como un verdadero catalizador para que nos ayudara
a crear mucho hueso nuevo.
Es un método que llamamos
el "biorreactor in vivo" y pudimos crear
enormes cantidades de hueso usando este método.
Y de esto voy a hablarles.
Lo que hicimos es que,
en humanos, todos tenemos una capa de células madre
en el exterior de nuestros huesos largos.
Esta capa se llama el periostio
y esa capa está normalmente
muy firmememente pegada al hueso oculto
y contiene células madres.
Esas células madre son en efecto importantes
en el embrión cuando se desarrolla
y también digamos que despiertan si se fracturan
para ayudarles a reparar el hueso.
Así tomamos esa capa de periostio
y desarrollamos una forma de inyectarle por debajo
un líquido que luego de 30 segundos,
se convierte en una gel rígida,
que puede levantar el periostio y separarlo del hueso
Así en esencia se crea una cavidad artificial
que está justo a un lado del hueso
que también tiene una capa abundante en células madre.
Y lo hacemos a través de una fina incisión
tal que ninguna otra célula del cuerpo puede entrar
y lo que pasa es que esa cavidad bioreactora in vivo artificial
puede conducir a la proliferación de estas células madre
que puede formar mucho tejido nuevo
y con el tiempo, se puede cosechar ese tejido
y usarlo en cualquier otro lado del cuerpo.
Esta es una platina histológica
de lo que vemos cuando hacemos eso
y en esencia lo que vemos
son grandes cantidades de hueso.
En esta imagen, pueden ver el centro de la pierna,
es decir médula ósea,
entonces pueden ver el hueso original
y pueden ver donde el hueso original termina
y justo a la izquierda de éste es el hueso nuevo
que ha crecido dentro de la cavidad bioreactora
y de hecho se puede hacer más grande.
Y esa demarcación que pueden ver
entre el hueso original y el nuevo
actúa como un muy leve punto de debilidad,
así ahora el cirujano puede
cosechar ese hueso nuevo
y el periostio puede volver a crecer
así se quedan con la pierna
en el mismo estado, por decir,
como si no lo hubieran operado en primer lugar.
En términos de dolor post operatorio es mínimo
comparado con la cosecha de una cresta ilíaca.
Y se puede generar distintas cantidades de hueso
dependiendo de cuánta gel pongamos,
así que en realidad es un procedimiento a pedido.
Ahora, cuando hicimos esto,
recibimos mucha atención de la prensa,
porque es una forma en verdad espléndida
de generar hueso nuevo
y recibimos muchos contactos
de diversas personas interesadas en usarlo.
Sólo les contaré
de algunos de esos contactos muy extraños,
levemente inesperados
y el más interesante,
permitan que lo diga así, fue un contacto que tuve,
de hecho de un equipo de jugadores de fútbol americano
que todo lo que querían era doblar el grosor de sus cráneos
hecho con sus cabezas.
Sí, llegan a tener este tipo de contactos
y por supuesto, siendo una británica
que también creció en Francia,
suelo ser muy brusca
y tenía que explicarles de una forma decente
que en su caso particular,
eso probablemente no haría mucho
para protegerlos en primer lugar.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Este fue nuestro método
y fue con materiales simples
pero lo pensamos con cuidado.
Sabemos que estas células
en el cuerpo, en el embrión, conforme se desarrollan
pueden formar distintos tipos de tejido, cartílago,
así desarrollamos un gel que era ligeramente diferente
tanto en su naturaleza como en química,
que puesta ahí, pudimos
obtener 100% de cartílago.
Este método funciona muy bien, pienso,
para procedimientos pre-planeados,
eso es algo que se debe preplanear.
Para otro tipo de operaciones,
en definitiva existe una necesidad de
otros métodos basados en estructura.
Cuando piensan en diseño
esas otras estructuras, de hecho,
necesitan de un equipo multidisciplinario.
Así nuestro equipo tiene químicos,
biólogos celulares, cirujanos e incluso médicos
y todos ellos se juntan
y reflexionan a fondo en el diseño de los materiales.
Pero queremos que tengan suficiente información
para que podamos obtener las células que queremos,
pero no a un grado de complejidad que dificulte
acudir a la clínica.
Así una de las cosas que reflexionamos mucho
es tratar de entender
la estructura de los tejidos del cuerpo.
Si pensamos en hueso,
obviamente mi tejido favorito,
aumentemos, podemos ver,
incluso si no saben nada de estructura ósea,
está bellamente organizado, realmente bellamente organizado.
Tenemos muchas venas aquí.
Si aumentamos otra vez, vemos que las células
están en efecto rodeadas de una matriz 3D
de fibras a nano escala y que dan
mucha información a las células.
Si aumentamos otra vez,
en el caso del hueso, la matriz
alrededor de las células está bellamente organizada
a nano escala y es un material híbrido
que es parte orgánico, parte inorgánico.
Y eso lleva al campo entero,
que ha visto el desarrollo de materiales
que tienen esta estructura híbrida.
Les muestro sólo dos ejemplos
de algunos materiales que hemos hecho que tienen esta estructura,
y que pueden confeccionar.
Pueden ver uno muy blandito
y un material que también es este tipo de material híbrido
pero que tiene una dureza notable,
que ya no es quebradiza
Y un material inorgánico normalmente sería muy quebradizo
y no podrian tener
este tipo de fuerza y dureza en él.
Otra cosa que quiero mencionar rápido
es que muchas de las estructuras que hicimos son porosas y tienen que serlo,
porque quieren que las venas crezcan ahí.
Pero a menudo los poros
son mucho más grandes que las células
y aunque es tridimensional,
la célula podría verlo más como una superficie ligeramente curva
y eso es algo no natural.
Así una de las cosas que podemos pensar hacer
es hacer estructuras con dimesiones ligeramente diferentes
que podrían rodear a las células tridimensionalmente
y darles un poco más de información.
Hay mucho trabajo que se está haciendo en ambas áreas.
Para finalizar quisiera hablar un poco de
aplicar esto a enfermedades cardiovasculares.
porque esto es un gran problema clínico.
Una de las cosas que sabemos,
es que si por desgracia tienen un ataque cardiaco
ese tejido puede empezar a morir
y con el tiempo el resultado no podría ser bueno para Uds.
Sería en realidad grandioso,
si pudiéramos detener ese tejido [dañado]
ya sea de morir o ayudarle a regenerarse.
Hay infinidad de pruebas con células madres ocurriendo en todo el mundo
y usan muchos tipos diferentes de células,
pero un tema común que parece surgir
es que muy a menudo ese células morirán
una vez implantadas.
Sea que las pongan en el corazón
o en el sistema sanguíneo,
como sea, parece que no podemos
llegar al número correcto de células,
llegar al lugar al que queremos
y poder entregar la regeneración
celular adecuada que quisiéramos tener
para conseguir buenos resultados clínicos.
Entonces algunas cosas que pensamos
y muchos otras personas del medio piensan también,
es desarrollar materiales para eso.
Pero he aquí una diferencia.
Todavía necesitamos de la química, de la mecánica,
de la interesante topografía
y todavía necesitamos formas interesantes que rodeen a las células.
Pero ahora, a las células también
probablemente les gustaría un material
que pudiera ser conductivo,
porque las células mismas responderían muy bien
y conducirían señales entre ellos.
Puede verlos ahora
palpitando en sincronía en estos materiales,
y eso es un desarrollo muy muy emocionante
que está ocurriendo.
Para cerrar, quisiera decir que
el poder trabajar en este campo,
todos los que trabajamos en este campo,
que no sólo es ciencia super emocionante,
sino que tiene el potencial
de impacto en los pacientes,
no importa cuán grande o pequeño sea
es en verdad un gran privilegio.
Y por eso, quisiera agradecerles también.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)